For Better or For Worse how do you wish  you were more like your character  it is both for better and for us because  I think I think fleabag says what she  thinks whether it's to the camera  privately or in real life she says what  she really really thinks in the moment  and I think I'm still learning how to do  that writing for me and writing these  characters for me is like how I do that  so I write women who don't give a [ __ ]  because I'm teaching myself how to be  one and yeah I feel such a catharsis  when I do turn to the camera and just  like say that [ __ ] line and then oh  it's just such an amazing feeling I'd  like to be a bit more like that really